so
the first year of my recovery after
coming out of back surgery going to
liver treatment
working my wife and my children were
still in my life my wife has just been
one that has decided that i'm never
going to leave you no matter what and
our family is most important
we had our families go to a family
program at the betty ford children's
program in order to give them a voice
and be able to um process their feelings
of anything they may have witnessed
which was so important to me and
important to my recovery as i went
through the journey of the first year of
my recovery which was still so much pain
so much hurt and a lot of fear
after i was finished with my day labor
and i just wasn't able to work because i
had a back brace on
now troy gave me a great suggestion he
said why don't you go back to the place
that
it all began at the rescue mission in
india
but this time i want you to be a
volunteer so every tuesday and every
thursday i would just go down there and
just be around the place that where i
first found my recovery and i used to
work
so i would pick up trash do the
gardening
talk to people and that's where the
beginning of my healing process came
i knew that i had to go back to where it
all started where it ended and keep
working with others even though deep in
my heart when i was in treatment and i
was going through everything i said i'm
never going to work with another person
i'm never going to help somebody get
clean and sober because i still had a
lot of anger with inside of my heart
and so i was just trying to find a
little bit of work at the time to
provide for francis and my children and
with troy's help i realized sometimes
there's a lot more than just earning
money can be volunteering or giving back
to an organization or trying to help
somebody without wanting anything in
return
all along in the first year
i still had court cases i got into a lot
of criminal trouble
i would have to go to court like once
every couple months with a lot of long
postponements but there was always the
hope that maybe a judge would see what i
did and that i'm clean and sober again
and i'm going into my first year and my
second year of my recovery and maybe
there was a hope they would have mercy
on me
as i was getting into the second year of
recovery i still didn't have a job
and i remember i was
hiking down a trail and i was just
questioning i was like why why can't i
get a job why can't i provide for my
family i'm going to meetings i'm clean
and sober i'm on the right track again
where have i gone wrong
and i got a call from somebody at the
rescue mission that said mark do you
want to work part-time i said i'll take
it whatever it is
and that's how i got back to working in
the field was driving a truck on the
weekends picking up all the donations
and bringing it back for our kitchen and
to give out food boxes uh you know it
was a humble beginning and it was what
was needed in my life
you know i think so many times when i
work around there i hear people say why
doesn't people just change their lives
and give up those drugs
why don't they just stop using why don't
they stop drinking
and i just wanted to share that
if we were to close our eyes right now
and we would think about the hardest the
time the most we were sick in our lives
we had the biggest cold or some people
fell with covid and we just couldn't get
out of bed and we were in so much pain
and we were running back and forth to
the bathroom every five minutes just
sick sick sick not being able to move
i try and describe that as asking
somebody to detox
where the pain is so great
and sometimes in our addiction the pain
is so great mentally
physically
emotionally that we're just stuck and we
can't move
and i think back and i look around and i
see all the homeless people and all the
homeless people i work with on the
streets they all say the same mark can
you promise me that it'll be painless
and i can't
i can't promise them it'll be painless
and until we improve on that i don't
think we're ever going to move the
needle
and try and make a difference in our
society with the homeless problem we
face
the pain also pain is the greatest
teacher they always say that
it's what we know
where not to go in life and what not to
do is through pain
and all of my pain
and all of my tragedies and all the
stuff i've experienced in life i could
say
i can internalize it and go okay
i'm just so mad at this and my childhood
was horrible and i never got a shot and
all that pain and all that frustration
and all the horrible things i've
witnessed i could just turn it against
myself
and use drugs and drink and do things
that are just out of control
or
i decided what i'm gonna do
is i'm going to turn all that around and
i'm just going to serve others
and that's been my life's work
i decided in my first year of recovery
heading into my second year of recovery
yes i'm going to meetings and
and i'm doing everything i have to do
and i'm a volunteer and i'm a coach for
the local little league football teams
but i need to give back
there was a reason why i went through
everything in my life
and that is to help another person and
so i work with the homeless
i work on outreach teams
nine different cities we set up
i started working back and getting more
into a counseling role where i was able
to work with the homeless once again
and it's important when a person wants
to know well you don't get where i'm
coming from and you don't know what it's
like to be an addict you don't know what
it's like to be addicted to heroin you
don't know what it's like to go to jail
or to go to prison and i could look down
and look them straight in the eye and
say yes i do
because i've been there i've been
exactly where you're at and i know what
it takes to get out of it
and i think that's what makes the
difference is when we have that
connection and they know that i've been
there and they have been there and
together we can get them the help they
need
i've worked under
we've go under bridges in the desert
and that was the second year where i was
just starting to get back to where i was
supposed to be and where i went away
from
but all along knowing that
my job does not define who i am and what
i do doesn't define who i am i'm a
father
i'm a parent i'm a little league coach
i'm a friend i'm a sponsor
and i do a lot of things outside of my
work to protect my own sobriety and to
protect myself and what i'm doing so i
make sure that i never ever return
up until this point in the first to
second year i'm still living at a sober
living house because i felt like it
wasn't enough time
i needed to be sure that i was solid
so my wife and my kids she was living in
an apartment i was living in a sober
living house because i was just like i
don't know if we want to bring it back
together plus i'm still fighting and
working to get through this court battle
and the whole time trying to find a way
to talk to our children about it because
we just don't know what could happen
but i just wanted to just keep having
faith in knowing you know what i'm going
to stay clean and sober i'm going to
keep working with others i'm going to
keep making a difference in my community
i'm going to go out there and share my
story with as many people that can hear
what i'm saying to try and get them in
to change their lives
and the day was coming close
and we kept fighting my case and
fighting my case and i went to court
something like 20 25 times and this is
all in my cup recovery still to staying
clean and sober and still working with
others and hope that the judge would
have mercy on me
and i remember going back and forth to
court and it was just weighing on my
wife and weighing on my children and
my life coach troy was like mark just
hang in there and keep going on and i
said one day i woke up and i said
i can't move on with my life
i can't i can't do this anymore
i don't know what to do frances and she
just said mark what do you want to do
i just said i just want to just
surrender
i just want to surrender to the courts i
just want to go in there
and just raise my hand and say i'm done
fighting
and right there everything changed for
me
and i was somewhere around three years
clean and sober
and i remember calling my attorney and
said i'm done fighting i can't fight
anymore
i have a wife i have two children at
home and i can't move on with my life
with this hanging over
so one day
we went to court
and we pled to the court
and i pled mercy and i asked him
please have mercy not just for me but
for my children and my wife
and i would like to say there's a
rainbow at the end of this story but
there wasn't
at the time they just said no mark
you're gonna have to do 300 days in jail
and i
just was so taken back
i said i'm three years clean and sober
i've done everything i can
i've changed my life but there was still
a price to pay
i couldn't understand why
but i know now that there's a price to
pay for everything we do
and i was willing to pay the price
and i accepted the plea for 300 days in
county jail
in hopes that we could write some more
letters
hire some people to evaluate my risk and
maybe there would be a a break maybe the
judge would just come around and say
it's going to be okay
and here we are heading up to the court
date
and i'm at home
hoping i get that call from my
attorney's office to say you know what
they're going to give you a break you
don't really have to go into jail
and i remember getting the call
from kelly the night before and she said
mark
you have to prepare yourself
and i was preparing the couple weeks
before that because i had to make sure
that my wife and kids were going to be
okay that the bills were paid that there
was enough food in the house that
francis had enough money and we made all
the arrangements and we made family
members we put everybody on notice we
knew that the day would come
and i remember that call came in about 6
30 7 00 at night
and she said mark you're gonna have to
go in tomorrow
and i remember going to the bathroom and
i locked the door so the kids wouldn't
hear me cry
because i was like man
i changed my life i got back over to the
right side
and now i got to go to jail and i'm
going to leave my kids alone again and i
remember promising my son i was like
junior i'm never going back
i'm always going to be here for you
after we got back together and we were
in
the ranch recovery center and i told
that part of my story and that was like
my commitment to my children
and uh
i knew i had to do the right thing and
explain it to my son
and i opened up the door and i went to
his room and he's in his little cubby
his little
you know we have twin beds and he's got
a little hideaway in there and i say hey
bud
can i talk to you and he's just playing
on his tablet i said junior i need to
talk to you
i need to tell you about what's going to
happen tomorrow
because your daddy has to go pay a price
price for something i did wrong in life
and it's time junior
and he kept staring down at the tablet
and he would look at me and i said
junior please
turn around and look at me i want to see
you i want to tell you i'm just so sorry
and he said that i can't
i said why he goes because every time i
think about it i just want to cry
because i don't want to lose my daddy
and i said junior
you're never going to lose me i just got
to go handle this
he said okay dada
he said but we're going to make a deal i
said we'll make a deal and my son is ten
mind you nine at the time
he said dada
when this is all over you promise me
that we'll never talk about this again
and i said deal junior
i called troy and i said troy it looks
like i have to go in
and troy said mark you got to do what
you have to do because it's going to be
a message for the others that you're
going to help in your life
that sometimes you have to do the hard
things in life you got to lift the heavy
weights even when you don't want to you
can't run mark you've been running your
whole life you have to own this
i said you're right troy
so i prepared myself the best i could
and in the morning i got dressed up the
best i could i'm shirt and die
and i went to troy's house
and we had to drive all the way to
blythe california which is in the middle
of the desert and i tell that
part because i want to explain something
that was so moving to me
we got in his car
he said are you ready to go
i said i'm as ready as i could be
i kissed the children kiss my wife
goodbye
and i told her don't worry everything's
gonna be okay we're gonna get through
this
and i remember driving all the way out
to blythe and if you've ever driven out
to blythe there's nothing but desert
nothing but desert and we get so caught
up in our lives in the busyness of our
lives and always trying to achieve
something and move forward in life
but when you know where you're going is
not going to be good and you're going to
jail all pets are off
we drove across that desert where there
was nothing but desert for miles you
can't see anything
and i thought about three things my wife
and both my children
and that was all that mattered that day
all that mattered
and i went to court
and the judge
took me into custody
and i'll tell you that's the first time
i've ever been clean and sober going to
jail
and even the bill have said i almost
feel bad arresting you because you're
probably the best dressed person i've
ever taken into custody
and i remember having to you know they
take you and they have to book you and
she said mark
i don't know
what you're feeling and what you're
going through but that judge does not
hate you i said i think he's pretty mad
at me he said no you'll see mark
i said okay
and they booked me into blythe county
jail and i was facing 270 days
and i remember going those long call
cold hallways where you got to change
out all your clothes and there was so
many messages being sent to me along the
way that i didn't understand like the
main jailer said
you know mark don't get too comfortable
around here because you'll probably get
fed kicked
i don't know anything about that stuff
i'm just here to do my time i don't want
to get hurt i don't want to pick up a
case i just want to love my family and
just get through this
made a couple calls to francis and i
just went from sell to sell to sell to
sell oh my god i never got housed
at two o'clock in the morning they woke
me up they said well we're transferring
you all the way back to india i'm like
why i'm here
two o'clock in the morning they
transferred me all the way to the indio
county jail in a van
with all kinds of people that were
facing life sentences and just it was an
interesting couple of days for sure
so i just drove all the way out there i
was so tired i wasn't able to sleep i
was on concrete bench to concrete jail
to this the rattling of the jail the
cages you're in your orange jumpsuit i'm
just trying to process everything and
they get me all the way up in the gel
and they put me in another freezing cold
sale and i'm just sitting there i don't
even want to call home because all
francis did the first time is just cry
and i told her baby don't cry
everything's going to be okay we're back
together
and we're a family and no matter what
we're not going to give up we're not
going to turn away from each other i'm
going to be okay and everything's gonna
work out no matter what
and i remember just being in from cell
to cell they never housed me
and i remember sitting on that cold
bench with a massive headache
and i slid down on the ground and i said
god i had it all wrong
my whole life
all the pain
all the abusive drugs and alcohol
in and out of jails i had it all wrong
it's all wrong
drugs and alcohol are not the answer to
anything
all the pain we experience in our life
is not the answer
the answer is
that we have to just serve others we
have to use these two hands not to
consume the world not to just always be
trying to get more we need to use what
we have as individuals as people and it
was my promise right there that for the
rest of my life i would help others
and shortly after that a couple people
came by and then this jailer came to my
door
and i'm approaching the second day and
the jailer says
mr mcgowan i go yes she goes come with
me and i'm like oh great i'm finally
going to get a cell and i can get some
sleep
she has my clothes that i dressed out in
and i look at her i go what's that
and she goes
here's your clothes go ahead and get
dressed you're going home i said what
she goes you're being federally kicked i
go i don't understand that i'm not
getting dressed i'm already thinking i'm
not going to get in trouble hope they're
not going to say i'm trying to escape or
something i don't want to get dressed
she came back again she said you better
get dressed right now or where you're
going to be in a lot of trouble i said
okay
i don't understand this
so i get dressed in my clothes and i go
all the way downstairs and they do all
my stuff to release me i'm like i don't
why am i being released when i just got
here
and i remember being in another cell in
this big jailer this big sergeant walks
up big burly guy
he says mr mcgowan is this you i go yes
sir he said uh
well we don't have room for you anymore
in the jail
so we're going to federally release you
we have a judge's order to release you
today i said excuse me you're gonna
release me why would you release me
he said sir
when you get released do me a favor go
back to what you were doing
and i never seen him again
and all i thought was
go back to what you were doing and
that's just helping other people get
clean and sober
and i walked all the way down this long
hallway and i could see the street right
there
and i have all my clothes and i'm like
i don't even want to call my wife
because if this is a joke i'm going to
break her heart
i didn't even call her
i couldn't even believe it and they got
outside and i looked back and the door
shut
and i called her i said
hey baby what are you doing she goes
what are you doing i go i'm walking down
the street she said that's impossible i
said i'm walking down the street in
india
and she was at the park playing with
troy's kids because they made a
commitment to my family
that they would check in on francis
every day and make sure my children had
enough food and
that the rent was paid and
that our children would have love while
i was in jail
and so they were at the park with junior
and ellie
and junior was like mom what's wrong
what's wrong with dad she said nothing
we're gonna go pick them up
and they drove all the way out to india
and juniors just can't believe it he
gets out of the car
and i'm sitting on the curb and i just
still can't even believe i'm out
and he runs up to me and that little kid
gives me the biggest hug ever
almost knocked me on the ground
i said but junior
he goes dada
remember our deal
i go what's that we're never talking
about this again
now let's go home
and that was it
and it was just amazing how fast it
happened
i one minute i thought i was going in
again
and they all knew and they just walked
me straight out the door
and i did exactly what that jailer said
go back to what you were doing
and when i went back i had a new fire in
my stomach to help even more people it
was like that was just god's way of
saying look mark you're in the right
place at the right time to help a lot of
people
and i just started moving up at the
rescue mission
our family came together after that
i know that
with the court case behind me and i knew
that jail wasn't the outcome
it was finally the day to leave the um
sober living home
and uh we left the silver living i left
the sober living house
and our family was back together again
under one roof
after almost four and a half years when
i lost our home
and i went into treatment
i was like three years into it
and we were finally together again as
one family
and there was a lot of financial
struggles along the way a lot of stuff i
had to pay off because i believe that
something else my coach taught me that
if you make the debt you have to go back
and pay the debt
so we had a lot of financial struggles
everybody has financial struggles but we
just worked on through it
i kept going to my meetings i'm clean
and sober
working with others
went back to college made up a bunch of
courses
went back to get a certification in drug
and alcohol counseling so that i would
have more
of a professional side of me and my
counseling
we worked on cooling centers we
developed a
um outreach team to serve nine different
cities
to trucks all day long just helping the
homeless helping the homeless helping
the homeless
and our family came back together
for the first time in a long time and
that was just an amazing moment for me
to realize that sometimes in life we
have to do the hard things and we have
to pay a heavy price
and troy has stayed with me the whole
time
helping me with my self-care program
teaching me how to be a better man a
better father a better human being and i
know through that whole thing that i'm
just a different human being when i help
others
i know there's so much talk about the
homeless so much talk about addiction so
much talk about
alcoholism and i know that we just we
have to stop and realize that
so many times we just want to give up on
people and we want to give up hope
we can't we have to work together and
know that each and every one of us has a
unique story to tell
i have my unique story somebody else has
their unique story and we never know
when we're the right person talking to
somebody to make change and it'll work
a lot of times it's just getting to know
a person
a homeless person somebody who's
addicted somebody who's working the
street some a prostitute whatever it may
be
that they're all part of our race
they're all part of us
and so when i help people i always help
people and i know i know for a fact that
i'm no better and no worse than the
person i'm helping
that each individual is different
recovery does work
people can change
if i can change i'm an addict i'm an
alcoholic i'm a heroin addict i've been
homeless i've lived underneath jackson
street bridge i've been beaten up i've
been in prison i've been around gangs
i've been involved with all the hard
horrible horrible stuff in life that
many people said this guy's no good just
lock him away for life
but for some reason people saw something
different in me and they kept trying and
they kept trying and yes i had to make a
decision to change
but not only did i make a decision to
change to stop drinking to stop using to
stop all the criminal behavior but i
made a decision to say you know what i'm
going to go back out there and i'm going
to help as many people as i can no
matter what their condition is whether
it's this tent on the corner with
somebody living in it asking for help i
want to be there i want to answer the
call because that call was given to me
and i realized a long time ago that
these hands were meant to help
if i do one thing right in this world
every last breath i take i want to help
a homeless person because i have seen
and i have witnessed the incredible
stories
of people coming in addicted
homeless
struggling
they've been in and out of prisons they
get in they get clean they get sober
they change their ways
they find a purpose they find substance
in their life they know that they're
better than everything that everybody
has told them they go out and get a job
they learn how to save money
they get an apartment they find a place
to live and they change their life
but it's more important that we go back
and we share that story with somebody
else
that then can change their lives
and i know at the end of the day
all the horrible stuff i've experienced
in life
is for one purpose
so i can sit across the table from
somebody and say
i totally get what you're coming from i
totally understand because i've been
there
and i'm just so grateful for the people
along the way that have helped me like
my wife never gave up on me
she never turned her back on me
she never stopped believing in me and
she never left me francis is like a rock
in my life and troy anderson my life
coach
and so many people along the way but
troy
has never judged me
never ever looked down on me always took
me for the person i am and see the
potential i am
i just want to
you know make sure that i'm the best
version of me
[Music]
authentic and living up to my full
potential so my children can see that in
me because that's the other thing is
that we have to remember our children
and the next generation and how do we
make a difference in people today and in
recovery and in treatment and
homelessness because there's a lot of
little children following them around
that the children
is our future and so we have to remember
that everything we do today we have to
live for our children i live for my
children but i also
raise them in a certain way and i always
made a promise to myself
that every morning i wake up i always
tell them i love you both and not today
i'm gonna go out and help as many people
as i can
because i still believe in people i
still believe that human beings can
change and nobody's ever gonna tell me
anything different all the news all the
horrible stories
i believe
in the human spirit the nature and the
desire to change
and i always told people people ask me
all the time i go why is it with all
this homeless people mark and i tell
people all the time i say you know what
i highly doubt when we were in fifth and
sixth grade or any of these people any
of these adults grew up saying you know
what
i hope and aspire to be homeless
to be addicted
to have to sell my body
to have to get into fist fights to join
a gang to go to jail none of them grew
up saying that that's what i hope and
wish to be that's the answer
every little kid every little boy every
little girl has dreams they have
aspirations but something went wrong
along the way whether it be trauma
whether it be something that they saw in
their parents something that they're
emulating something they think is cool
and then along the way
a series of bad choices problems mental
illness diagnosis
they land homelessness
there they are homeless on the corner
but nobody ever was first sought out in
life to be that at the end
i don't believe that because i don't
ever want to give up on another person
and i never will because people didn't
give up on me
they didn't give up on me because they
knew that i had potential far greater
than the way i was living
and so inside of me that's my life work
all i want to do is work with the
homeless find the next mark mcgowan out
there and hopefully they'll do great
things in their community
and that's what i just want to encourage
everybody to believe we have to believe
in ourselves we have to believe in our
neighbor we have to believe in our
children we have to believe that people
can change not only can they change but
they can go back and make a great
difference in life but if we don't
believe in that change and we stop
believing in other people
we're just going to give up on everybody
as a whole
and i don't want to do that and if
you're seeing this today
find somebody you can help find somebody
in need
because you never know when you're going
to help somebody
that's actually going to help you and
move your spirit as you're helping
somebody else
amazing talk thank you mark thank you
thank you for having me
beautiful
you